all right strap in folks this is the
biggest film you will see on the
tv but okay months after all the wonder
woman 1984
promo merch hit the candy aisle in your
local grocery store the movie's upon us
that goes along with that promo merch
okay let's do it
[Music]
wonder woman 1984. so wonder woman 1984
is the sequel to the patty jenkins
directed wonder woman film
from 2017. once again you have patty
jenkins as the director in the driver's
seat you have gal gadot as wonder woman
chris pine and steve trevor we have a
new villain played by pedro pascal we
also have kristen wiig with the buildup
of cheetah bad
things are coming to the earth in 1984
and events that will happen and
transpire in which
does anybody in the dc eu remember these
events
that is the question i find it
interesting i don't know why they would
mention it
what's batman going to be like
marshmallow flight time in 1984 like why
would they mention it i don't know the
point is there were things that worked
in this movie at the top
we have gal gadot's wonder woman i mean
this isn't just her second movie being
wonder woman either she's been wonder
woman in one of the four movies right
four
fifth if you include the snyder cat i
mean she's better in wonder woman 1984
than she was in the original wonder
woman she's so good at wonder woman at
this point
she makes me feel bad for doubting her
ever in wonder woman the original wonder
woman there were a couple of emotional
scenes i was like i didn't
really stick the landing with me as much
as i imagined the movie
wanted to wonder woman 1984 there are a
couple of emotional scenes and
absolutely sticks to landing more also
steve trevor and the wonder woman steve
trevor dynamic once again chris pine is
back as steve trevor and i was a little
afraid i thought it was going to be like
up
same shtick different movie and the
previous wonder woman movie wonder woman
was from themascara
and she comes to our world she comes to
our world she's a fish out of water
steve trevor's her guide so it's
fun to see her navigate our world or at
least
our world as it was in world war one but
this fish had a water scenario they had
it worked because it's just a fun way to
poke at the absurdities
of us of humans in wonder woman 1984 now
wonder woman's been
in our world for decades she's been here
for a while she knows how it operates
and now steve trevor is the fish out of
water because he hasn't been around
since world war one i was afraid he was
just gonna feel old but they do enough
in this movie to keep it feeling new
because it's not really the same
kind of eyes looking at the world wonder
woman wasn't from our world at all she
knew nothing of our
human idiosyncrasies completely new
experience for her so it is different
having someone who knows nothing about
the world and someone who
knew about the world decades ago just
isn't familiar with it now but they saw
where
it was it's kind of like that episode of
star trek the next generation called
relics where scotty is in an episode of
star trek the next generation he opens
up the dilithium crystal chamber he's
like
don't you know that your dilithium
crystals are going to fracture and
jordy's like we recomposite the crystals
while they're still inside you know so
he knows about dilution crystals he just
doesn't understand how the technology
has changed and evolved whereas if you
take someone from 1872 show them
diluting crystals they're going to be
like i know nothing about that so they
had a new spin
on that take they did from the first
wonder woman and it entertained me also
pedro pascal i thought pedro pascal was
actually really good now i'm not saying
in that
trump metaphor kind of way i've heard
that thrown around
i mean maybe he is maybe he isn't i
don't know i suppose if you want to see
that you're going to see it kind of like
in the bush administration
any movie that had to do with war at all
who was just like oh gi joe rise of
cobra
obviously it's a metaphor of george w
but it's not do i think ryza cobra came
out
after but point is suppose you're going
to see it if you want to see it
but when i'm talking about pedro pascal
from this movie when i'm talking about
maxwell lord i'm just talking about a
comic book movie villain i thought he
was a really good comic book movie
villain because he was different than
what i thought he was going to be i
don't know what i
expected from the guy i don't know what
i expected from the character but his
character
interested me and the logistics
surrounding the character and why he's a
threat i found it really compelling
because it's kind of unconventional you
know you don't just have
okay the super villain who's super
powered and the
superhero who's super powered and they
fight because that's what superheroes
and super villains do you have your
toe-to-toe fight kind of like lex luthor
and superman though lex luthor is much
more intellectual than
pedro pascal's character in this movie
pedro pascal is much more emotional it's
much more interesting much more
fascinating much more complex has much
more to tell about just
people in general humanity as a whole in
a world where wonder woman can't just
go beat up pedro pascal's character
because she'll literally
turn his head into silly putty if she
tries she punches him in the face i
guess they felt they need a big physical
fight at the end of this movie and
that's where cheetah comes in
but it does feel like cheetah was thrown
into this movie
just for that cheat is played by kristen
wiig and there are like three
phases of cheetah in this movie you have
barbara who's super awkward you know
she's not confident
so you need someone with that comedic
timing to deflect with jokes and
you know i thought she worked i thought
kristen wiig worked for that then she
gets a lot more confidence in this movie
again kristen wiig works for that her is
cheetah i don't know
i don't know because he didn't really
get a good look at her i didn't get a
good look at cheetah because the fight
takes place at night and they did that
because they're clearly doing that trick
that hollywood's been doing for years if
not
decades to hide shoddy cgi which is just
have the cgi take place at night but in
the end it was just this fight that
happens at the end for the sake of
it happening and that's the reason she's
in the movie i really didn't feel the
payoff with that not at all so after
that cheetah monologue i suppose we're
swinging into things
that didn't really land for me at the
beginning of the movie i thought it came
across as a bit cheesy
like the movie as a whole i'm not
talking the flashback scene
of her when she's a little girl and
she's in the mascara
that i didn't need because it didn't
really link to anything
i think she repeats a phrase from there
so
you can just have the phrase you don't
need build-up for a phrase i feel like
it's because rob and ryan all the
amazonians they were
they're under contract to be in the
movies or they were like all right we
got to fulfill that
let's have him in the movie all right a
flashback at the beginning that
really doesn't tie into anything but no
i'm talking about the mall throwdown
there was something about that
mall throw down it i felt like i was
watching a comic book movie
from 1984. you know that that kind of
cheese has now come
back to comic book movies i guess and
maybe that was the intent i just don't
think it did anyone any favors i don't
think it did the movie favors you could
tell
people were on strings the fight looked
a bit unnatural i don't know just
starting me off on the wrong foot for
this movie i was like okay well i guess
comic book movies have
gone back to this some of the other
effects also didn't seem too polished i
mean granted the last wonder woman movie
kind of fell into that also i don't know
if they're going for continuity but
there's a scene where she's running
after these trucks whereas like the
cadence of your feet and your speed
it looks like you're floating and not in
that oh she's wonder woman so she can do
that kind of way but more like
well the cgi it's it's really noticeable
kind of way and the movie's a bit too
long it feels a bit too long because
there are a lot of
elements in this movie that they're all
churning together and the movie is what
two and a half hours or something like
that it didn't really need to be it
could have just been
maxwell lord and for me that would have
been enough but now you had to build up
cheetah
for one fight to happen at the end of
this movie and that's the sole reason
that said the third act of wonder woman
1984 is a better
third act than the original wonder woman
movie if you take cheetah out of it like
by and large the third act of this movie
really did work for me granted by the
third act of this movie i was like
i've seen this in another movie this is
the third act
of another jim carrey movie it's like
someone saw the third act of this jim
carrey movie they were like but if we
put wonder woman in there
why not i don't know i just couldn't
help but think of it i would be baffled
if you don't hear that
in nine out of ten reviews it actually
has a good lesson a good plea for
humanity it
came across as a bit cheesy when it's
hammering at home sure
bit sappy but what can i say i'm a
cheesy sappy human so i guess it worked
for me but the first two acts of the
previous wonder woman movie i thought
were far superior than the first two
acts of this wonder woman movie wonder
woman 1984. that said i really dig gal
gadot and chris pines chemistry together
i really like the wonder woman steve
trevor dynamic that kept it going for me
also pedro pascal as maxwell lord those
three characters keep this movie afloat
absolutely there's a great movie
somewhere in here
it doesn't always shine through i
thought it was a good time no alcohol
required all right so wonder woman 1984
coming to hbo
max on the 26th i think are you looking
forward to it or if you're watching this
review
after the 26th and you've already seen
it did you enjoy it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you